you
Oh miss stars our critic I've never been
so happy in my entire life
Oh hyper fangirl being with you makes me
completely forget the fact that there's
an assassin watching me through with you
find her he really does blend into the
background after a while doesn't he like
the pecking of Satan's Fulcher come on I
want to show you my humble abode you
know not that being kidnapped in force
at gunpoint to love someone isn't don't
I believe Porky's you forced me to put
it but how long do you plan to keep this
going
I told you until we reviewed Princess
Diaries two together it's always been my
dream to review a bad movie with you and
did that dream also involved toe
decapitation sometimes okay you're doing
a great job by the way I aim to please
hey I think you're really gonna like it
here oh sure you'll love a place around
it and pages of frozen fanfiction
I definitely underestimate the perks of
dating a psychopath
oh my god this place has everything oh
those all the fast and furious movies
yep
is that Marvel vs. Capcom 3 point 5
point 6 yep oh this the mass arguably
the most violent comic ever drawn on
paper yes before Jamie Kennedy that was
the most terrifying rendition known to
man this place is amazing I kind of
shocked you can afford it
oh this one time i stalked joe dante and
when I found out what he did with his
Barbies and his private time it gave me
a great Beverly this place is like a
salute to testosterone adolescence I'm
kind of shocked you're into all this
well Oh mojo don't you two have a movie
to review thank you Betty
what do you say critic are you ready to
review an old nostalgic bad movie well
given these surroundings and maybe won't
be as bad as I thought good because
you're gonna need that mentality to get
through it
this is the sequel to the 2001 Disney
hit Princess Diaries reinforcing every
little girls dream that your ordinary
life can be transformed into a fairy
tale if you discover you were pushed out
of the right couch
well definitely not Shakespeare even the
toughest critics can look deep into
their hearts and cheerfully declare this
film is harmless royal engagement
however takes whatever cliches we were
willing to overlook in the first film
and maximize them for shyamalan levels
no oh yes
Shyamalan levels this results in one of
the stupidest embarrassing and downright
insane sequels Disney has ever put out
and that's saying a lot giving their
lineup so critic are you ready to enter
the world of vagina pandering as long as
I have my penis pandering nearby I'm
good this is Princess Diaries two royal
engagement I didn't know they made a
video game of the purge actually that's
Grand Theft Auto 6 oh we open with the
graduation of our main character Mia
played by Anne Hathaway graduating from
high school Woodrow Wilson School of
Public and International Affairs
graduating class go horrible sequels
disappoint the fan faces you were never
meant to Keith as the credits roll we
see Mia doing something we ironically
never see me adieu in these movies right
now freakin diary well it's me
brand new college graduate slash
princess slash non-credible actress for
years thanks to films like this one
you're about to see this evening is my
21st birthday party and our tradition
says I have to dance with all the
eligible bachelors in Genovia she lands
her fake CGI plane over the poorly
rendered landscapes of generica where
she'll live with her grandmother played
by Julie Andrews but you're late your
majesty a queen is never late everyone
else is simply early
well her hearing must be gone now
there's almost as much blowing power in
those horns that there is in this movie
as you may recall in the first film she
had a nice romantic fling with a boy
named Michael but he's been banished to
the friend zone never to return
wait wasn't most of the last film trying
to get his attention being Disney should
they live like all happily ever after
and shit oh and one disney film for sure
but in a product producing sequel we
need more arm candy to put in tween
magazines this is where Nicholas comes
in played by Chris Pine I suppose is too
much to ask things come back in time
with USS Enterprise to take out Klingon
imposters nope
he's here to be the charming jerk shell
of course fall in love with while every
other suitor comedic Lee screws up and
unrealistic over-the-top way such a
fetish dilemma across places how do you
obviously don't speak English this is
for my party we'd be kissing by now
one three one two you know these guys
have a chance to bag a hottie and be
rich and powerful for the rest of their
days don't you think maybe a language
class and etiquette class hell even the
fucking dance class would be worth the
effort for that size of the Bachelorette
works harder
well that would distract from painfully
obvious Disney cameos like Raven
visiting all the way from the land of
stereotypical pausing go yeah
do you like my fake accent and terrible
costume I had a whole bunch of
kindergarteners make it for my new show
that's so racist but an evil villain
played by John rhys-davies has plans to
take the crown away from her and in case
you missed the unbelievably subtle music
foreshadowing that fact he practically
turns to the camera and announces it to
the audience we should be more careful
your royal highness somebody might try
to take that away from you thank you so
much for all your help someone like me
it's actually kind of amazing even
babies just born into this world could
pick up on the fact that he's the
villain without that being said it'd
probably make just as much sense to have
the movie go
Oh critic that's just an eye drop of how
unsubtle this movie is take for example
Mia's servants in the castle hi how's it
going come play with us Mia at your
service
I'm Ricky Thomas abrogating Brigitta
don't curtsy like that how do you like
it like this might be oh no no I didn't
mean like you know this IRA no no not
that way I didn't mean it at um the
Queen vis you good morning princess
she's in session with oh my god this is
one of those movies where instead of
laughing if they're silliness you're
questioning whether or not they were
dropped as infants either way you're not
gonna laugh so media stumbles across a
secret passage so obvious you swear the
fucking bat-poles were waiting for her
and he's dropped on a political meeting
because Parliament meets at the Queen's
House for some reason another genovian
of the royal bloodline became eligible
to assume the throne nephews mother was
my wife's sister I am pleased to say
that my nephew is ready to take his
place as genovia's rightful king ha
funny we didn't see that little gigantic
loophole coming all these years
hey come on they were too busy teaching
her how to sit properly it was much more
important you think princess Mia Faust
in line to a single friend the princess
must marry
we have never enforced that law a man
doesn't have to marry to be king
my granddaughter should be given the
same rights as any man yeah
the court will recognize the yeah that
came from the extremely opinionated
ventilating system too much a 60-day 30
days so the court allows me a 30 days to
find herself a husband so that she may
be able to rule the kingdom as Queen hey
to be fair 30 days is quadruple the time
given in most Disney movies but it's
okay because the Queen has a brilliant
strategy to foil the plans of our
obvious villain and his nephew have them
live in the palace of course giving them
much easier access to steal the crown
away shut up I am dead serious
oh no Parliament didn't invite him I did
there's any
mischief going on I'd prefer it be right
under my nose okay there's a big
difference between keeping your friends
close and your enemies closer and giving
your bank PIN number to a man in a black
and white striped shirt and a dark mask
I mean isn't like the equivalent of
saying hey here's a stabbing knife I'm
just gonna turn my back to the wall and
hope that nobody plunges it in there
anytime soon and you'll never guess who
the villains nephew who wishes to steal
the crown is why Chris Pine of course
spending most of his time hatching
diabolical schemes with his uncle Gimli
son of dawn your highness Lord Nicholas
Wow
I don't think I've actually seen a
live-action turning of the head going
hmm since watching Miss Piggy on the
Muppet Show to her credit I think Miss
Piggy was more subtle would you care to
explain what was going on out there yeah
your performance is making Minds look
like under actors if you'll come with me
I have something to show you I think you
could leave that right there
we are trading one feminine stereotype
for another feminine stereotype like
this franchises favorite running cliche
opening up doors and gawking at
materialism
I love these hmm
Marie Antoinette's line let them eat
cake is sounding more like a charitable
phrase compared to this gorgeous grab up
it kind of a letdown after the jingles
I'm not gonna live movie McGuirk face
I've come to lose credibility in my
movie to know I'll just let my
performance in hostile to do that so
they sit around partaking in feminine
stereotype number a trillion cheerfully
debating who she's gonna marry yes oh
yes I I absolutely accept Prince
William's he's not eligible because he's
in line for his own crown I do love how
one minute she's strongly against an
arranged marriage and then the next
she's scarfing down popcorn picking
which stud cake has the best royal
family jewels and
in Susa of Paris yeah he's cute his
boyfriend thinks he's handsome also
right on we're pro with something that
should distract from the fact that we're
saying nothing funny why'd they include
a gay guy in there anyway
but they finally find a prince who seems
eligible he likes long walks on the
beach while scarves are pulled by
strings has no character outside of
being chiseled like mythological Greek
porn and reacts perfectly with her
having no character outside of being
clumsy because well that's all Gary
Marshall has in his copy right bad
nothing runaway bride I guess not good
said cry like a bitch at the end of that
movie but evil son of duh tells his
nephew that he must try to romance Mia
if they are ever to get the crown he
finds her hiding from her servants why
are we whispering I'm my ladies Bates
because I'm not about being pampered and
materialistic except while being
pampered and materialistic so cool I'm
sorry is there something you wanted to
say to me you are the one who stomped on
me with your big feet big feet for Kate
I found her I'm not here it wasn't her
it was a post
I don't think Muppet Babies would have a
line that stupid
you see usually when I ask a woman to
dance I always show her my family tree
oh well you just crafty she's just
jealous because he stole her eyeliner
the point is that I'm on to you oh oh
boy am i on to what you are trying to do
and what am I trying to do is the most
cliched hiding place you could have
chosen this is this is Miss Honey please
take us to the Bahamas as hiding places
oh please keep your intuition your
highness
not ever no you don't hurt well I do
hope I doesn't distract her too much
from focusing on how to be a good Queen
oh don't worry they still have plenty of
time to teach her the most vital
information about being a political
leader like how to do archery how to
ride sidesaddle and most importantly how
to wave a fan we are learning with the
art of the fad wait a minute the
fade-out their kingdom lies in her hands
and they're focusing on fucking fan
waving unless she showed how to
decapitate a person alum Oertel combat
style I don't see the importance of that
well this movie feels that girls don't
want to actually learn about being a
good leader or ruling with intelligence
and wit they'd rather have all that fame
without that pesky responsibility even
when she watches the Queen with the
local farmers the biggest thing she
learns is how not to hold a chicken a
princess never chases a chicken I'm sure
that information will save us from
warring countries this movie doesn't
want to teach ain't good morals to girls
it's just pretending like it does while
partaking in a million stereotypes I
mean who wouldn't be desperate enough to
use gender manipulation to get what they
want uh critic could you hold on to my
collection of Playboy cartoons oh oh
this has the Silverstein collection I
also have to be ladylike while riding
sidesaddle impressively sneaky grandma
did you come up with this on your own
oh no it's a centuries-old idea you know
grandma I thought up some solutions for
this country's economic struggle nope
sidesaddle I recall princess died doing
a lot of charity work Oh sidesaddle I
don't even know the name of one town in
this
it's not a sidesaddle don't burn your
heretic unless you know sidesaddle the
tattle so while riding with her wooden
prosthetic and nobody noticing that the
other side of her dress has a leg size
bump silly son of lame has yet another
evil plan princess Mia's horse sandy
gets easily spooked by snakes so let's
get it really smooth shall we hmm this
is a fake snake gasps very dangerous
that's rubber yes but it will spook the
horse the rubber snake does end up
hooking the horse and Mia's leg is
officially pulled don't wonder she's so
clumsy she's got a wooden leg I like all
these men wearing helmets
what the hell is that about the Queen no
doubt three old about how well her plan
of having the villains stay with them is
going questions Chris Pine about his
motivation why are you so against
princess Mia being queen
my uncle feels that princess Mia doesn't
other people and you feel you do yes I
was born here I went to primary school
here I even have an accent in every
other sentence I need to be frank
she spent little time here since then
well how can one rule the people if they
do not know the people fine not so
surprisingly brings up a very legit and
obvious point that Andrews sucks as a
teacher and probably a queen so in order
to have me an O of the people she
introduces her to the point zero one
percent of the country because if
there's anything that history has taught
us it's the rich who need the most help
Alyssa and I were just discussing her
latest achievement she's received the
Rhodes Scholarship andrew has a PhD in
anthropology from Oxford Alyssa was in
the Peace Corps me and Pine exchange
they're obviously not fiance's who
obviously trust one another - obviously
not fall in love Andrew would you like
to get a drink I have a feeling they're
going to start her my horse is bigger
than your horse I would absolutely love
to excuse us Darren's do anything you
wouldn't do wait you can't just say
something like that and walk away I will
have you know that I am very attracted
to nd understands me and you Wow
what passion I loathe you oh I love you
it moves you first
hmm so remember kids if you constantly
bicker manipulate lie and insult one
another it's not a dysfunctional
relationship it's real ah oh good
everyone keeps telling me I'm crazy for
thinking that
I'd say ironically
you stay away from me look out folks
Webster do I want to know I don't think
so needless to say I met Chris Pine and
he made me win when are you going to
start acting responsibly when you start
teaching it God
she's scheduled for a very important
public waving down in Epcot Genovia when
she sees a little girl being made fun of
she stops the parade and pulls a
Jennifer Lawrence by getting out and
talking to her would you like to be a
princess today
I can't I'm too little why don't we get
you a tiara and you can wave and march
in the parade
Matt why don't you all take tiaras all
give them all free tiaras
I'll take care of it later thank you bTW
the price for tiaras has just suddenly
gone up a thousand dollars per plastic
Ruby
hugging offers what a vulgar low
despicable political trick right Gary
Marshall should be ashamed of himself
this causes her just a mere hour into
the movie to finally do something of
political good the children from the
shelter will be housed at the winter
castle in the mountains of Libet and
converted into a children shelter until
money can be raised for one of their own
no wait I'm sure you have to tie this
back to how to wear shoes or something
this also inspires her to gather all the
princesses from all over the world to a
gigantic get-together oh good are they
finally going to talk about using their
image for charity events or raising
awareness for global problems or let me
kill them now no no no safer Gary Hart
may I and now for the Royal stunt double
shut up the Queen sticks around as she
figures a spoonful of pandering makes
the awful scene go down what dude
well I might have tweaked it a little
bit on my computer but I don't know how
to do this thing some boys can roll them
back in again oh boy this is the most
out of nowhere impromptu dance since
Vanilla Ice saying go ninja go ninja go
can we just cut to all the poor genovian
peasants starving in the streets while
these little twats enter horrendously
expensive slumber party
you know I'm not gonna lie this movies
really starting to piss me off tell me
about it you know instead of trying to
inspire people they're just using their
hormones to achieve some sort of selfish
need yeah active MIT that does sound a
little familiar hey look guys I just
downloaded a wrestling video game where
you could be a mutant trifecta sergeant
slaughter Andre the Giant and Dwayne the
rock just oh my god I am so Larry yeah
look give you know something triple sho
Austin Hogan
you
meanwhile subtle son of obvious is not
pleased with how his diabolical plans
are going you can't believe that I am
hearing this you want her to rule after
all the effort that we are put in we
used a rubber snake damnit who used a
rubber snake and by the way if even now
you haven't realized that they're the
bad guys yet once again they announced
it to the audience because they just
don't think you're smart enough to
process their subtlety she's not the one
she's marrying is he/she please try to
keep up her data
he's trying to steal the crown I think
viewers of Dora the Explorer could
figure out faster where this movie is
trying to explain hey kid can you tell
who the villain is supposed to be before
pine has to go he has Mia to spend one
night with him in secret because you
know they sure to insult and bickering
and weird fountain sex The Maids tried
to distract her grandma while she sneaks
out Frere Jacques Frere Jacques
dormez-vous dormez-vous we never got to
finish our routine at the slumber party
so I'm in a routine dealing with you
ding dang dong ding dang dong what the
hell did I just watch
the most desperate moment and all of
comedy it will never be matched I mean
by heavenly Jesus the same company that
brought us the miracle of snow white the
majesty of Fantasia the breathtaking
size of Lion King and the groundbreaking
genius of Pixar has also delivered on to
us ding ding dong ding dang dong I feel
like a little humor in the world has
died and we'll never get it back not
a lot but enough to notice a chilling
emptiness like every single banging of
those pots is drilling a nail into the
heart of a clown
I don't think humor would be the same
again
ding dang dong ding dang dong
so our lovebirds partake in romantic
thumb-wrestling as most lovers do when
it turns out his uncle had them followed
by paparazzi you know it's really a
shame you didn't get juicier stuff last
night you jerk you don't understand it's
the third act we're supposed to hate and
misunderstand each other right now and
here's the Royal exclusive I promised of
course it makes it all over the news
thus Mia and Prince fiance debate what
they should do I still think this
marriage is a good idea anything I
really want to say yes but now there's
just there's no smack me to God you
think after knowing you for five days
and being forced to marry you there be
something but know this obvious
political calculated move just feels
sparkless but that doesn't stop them
from continuing the wedding and thus
everything is set for the big day
including a Stan Lee cameo I do better
if you and I get married oh um did I
miss something mr. Lee Disney hasn't
bought Marvel yet Oh
Disney is buying Marvel nothing two
years later I didn't know I was Ralph
Nader you're the president of Marvel him
don't put him in x-men days of future
paw I grew but just as the wedding is
about to take place with the villain
seated right in the front row why the
saboteurs get the best treatment in this
country Mia as the strong decisive Queen
we all know she's going to be bales in
the middle of the wedding because like
all good leaders but she just doesn't
know what to do now you can go back into
that church and get married or you can
walk away whatever choice you make
let it come from your heart things that
could have been brought to my attention
yesterday my sudden spaz attack loves
you so much so she calls off the wedding
and because all a parliament is there of
course makes a flee right there on the
spot to abolish the law saying she must
be married to rule I believe I will be a
great Queen I love Genovia do you think
that I would be up here in a wedding
dress if I didn't I moved to abolish the
marriage law as it applies to present
and future queens of Genovia I second
the motion
I I if I may say so myself
you rule by God if Abraham Lincoln
thought up such a groundbreaking speech
maybe we could have avoided the Civil
War
hey Congress of America I know it's just
a kegger in my house but you guys are
just so rad what do you say we abolish
slavery would it be cool it'd just be
cool just because I didn't get my
fairytale ending doesn't mean you
shouldn't but a wedding still takes
place as the Queen again
spur-of-the-moment decides to marry her
bodyguard Joe as they've been having a
secret romance that was secret to
nobodies my lord Archbishop I would like
to take this man as my husband if you
please
okay this wedding can still be saved at
John rhys-davies goes out to Mia and
whispers the Laster send their regards
you can figure out the rest I pronounce
you man and wife you may kiss the bride
this has got to be the weirdest day in
this country's history it would forever
be known in the history books as the
cool guys who did rad things it was just
like totally Shaw wedding as such
Mia keeps her romance going with pine
but decides not to get married until the
time is right that's focusing on being a
good Queen I promise to wave fans shoot
arrows and Biden parade floats until the
next talentless puppet comes to take my
place oh I'm gonna get a t-bone steak
and watch mindless Gorda basses
well I'm not gonna lie hyper fangirl now
is actually a lot of fun do you really
mean it
yeah surprisingly we like more things
than I thought maybe maybe we do have a
lot in common so yeah
Hey look she's got the Michael Bay
Transformers movies you like the Michael
Bay transformer movies uh no I hate all
of them
even the first one yeah no wait which do
you enjoy what come on just tell me
which ones you want me to like
transformers transformers - the first
one again transformers 3 the first one
again transformers for the rise of the
revenge the second first one again I see
what you're doing you're trying to play
to my inner manchild just like this
movies trying to play to every inner
woman child you're just trying to
manipulate the primal stupidity that
never wants to evolve in all of us did
it work
no we are having so much fun together
that's not love that's just enjoying the
same stuff aren't those the same things
it's just like this movie it doesn't
teach you it doesn't challenge you it
doesn't care if you're a better person
by the end all it cares about is that
you give it attention
further talk of girl power and being
independent all they're doing is
throwing the same lazy cliches at you so
you'll never crave anything different
they want to keep you in that primal box
so you'll never evolve and always want
the same thing over and over that way
they can keep selling you the same thing
over and over and don't have to try as
hard well love for art doesn't work that
way both the viewer and the artist need
to be invested if both are expected to
grow and I know what people say oh it's
a girly thing you wouldn't understand
what it's girly not to think it's girly
to accept whatever pandering bullshit is
thrown at you I mean don't get me wrong
I defected my stupid shit too but when
movie comes along plain and it has your
best interest in mind when clearly it
doesn't that's not love that's just
desperate
is this pronounce King dang dong ding
dang dong
that's what love is hyper fangirl it's
not about giving people what they want
it's helping them discover what they
need and the same love giving back in
return right up there
well I've discovered that we need to
watch the movie again
hyper no we just need to watch it one
more time and have a bunch of good
laughs and it's gonna be the best - oh
my gosh she's trying to play a movie
without the systems update no hyper
there's no ahead as we try to playful
these NASA systems update
when will people learn to read the
manual you think we'll ever see her
again critic
I just don't know Benny no well for one
viewers your popular will be the
deciding factor Oh second maybe she
isn't meant to be found love is a
strange thing
Benny sometimes you had to be away from
him for a while in order to fully
understand it but I can tell you this
Benny I'm no longer going to be bound to
the limitations of my gender it's time
to balance out excessiveness with
variety and intelligence indeed let's go
watch expendable three while reading
Jane Austen right
King ding dong ding ding dong